this is Startalk so did you did you put
graffiti on this kids shirt he was
standing there looking all proud stop
that so he'll never forget I said Polly
don't forget now you let this guy mess
up your shirts yes because you've got
more degrees in the month of July he was
in it and you don't even have like a
grade school degree yet you just yield
it to him yeah he told you to be curious
to be to be defiant in your search for
the truth and you just surrender to your
abilities wearing braces when trading
with seven yeah you got to take cute you
don't know how to do is try like holding
this thing here nobody cares if I look
at three meters and just dresses you
down completely I got the whole thing I
got your back I am your senator
represents you is a sight oh forget you
bring me your grape review um I'm from
Queens oak we cool you came over here
for this yeah oh cool you said it like
yeah of course you did okay okay so I
expect you to be on your best behavior
while you're in New Jersey if you malign
my stages I will come after you yeah all
of you over the river I'll be there he's
talking about the river hit him across
the river sovereign never good you can
calculate both make it to New York
just like the fights I get him with
Schumer on I remind him that when he
goes around telling people to be New
York giant it's not the New York giant
it is New Jersey giant on here sir thank
you very much thank you
here is your oh you guys all are you New
Yorkers dirty thank you God God we're
traveling you from Garfield is a great
town actually I don't know if Garfield
was named after Garfield
what do you guys know that an Iron Man
if the town was made up to the present
okay I'd actually actually know that I'm
going to look that up search the
internet with all truth that is there
for some presidents don't you know
they're just history just steps over
there Millard Fillmore did you know who
Millard Fillmore it's just it's just raw
match certain presidents are malign yeah
yeah anything they need no Wars going on
so you are a Jersey boy
well originally I'm short but now you're
Larry in Jersey I love why did you have
to put a caveat that standardized total
disclosure disclosure how you live in
out right bank yeah look radius your
representative here but my mom and I
won't work I work at the County Zoo yeah
it's my cousin stop great yeah you could
get your cousin a little correct
chemical - Jersey - no well yeah I
wanted to find it yeah oh no all right
well don't before so Jersey the pole
great how are you guys
we live in register where
good wholesome wholesome places in her
the results of the earthly people
so where did you talk about the urban
fraud where where did you grow up and I
grew up in the Bronx
Rob excuse me de bras the bra pronounce
that right otherwise so you are Viera I
was a Yankee fan when Chris Chambliss
when first Chambliss in Randolph was on
yeah yeah so so here's the thing Thurman
month
here's yes all of all of the above so
here's the thing so Yankees have won so
many championships it just so happened
that I was at formative age when they
had this gap where they didn't win
anything
it was like a like a nine-year gap and
all of my childhood years no champion so
what do you think to just take it out of
the pit stop you say trim the lawn yeah
pretty much pretty much and then they
finally come around was in 1977-78 yeah
I finally won one which when I was his
age yes they went 10 11 years without
without a championship anyway and then I
didn't realize how spoiled I was to
complain about ten years Chris oh come
some teen hand and the one a champion oh
I have one since the name cool 20s so I
felt bad upon realizing that I had taken
that for granted so baseball the game
with a lot of superstition yes it is you
as a scientist you look down upon the
superstitions like you don't shade while
you're on a street do you like look at
those people yet that you were so a
scientific I am highly non superstitious
just as a person yes I mean any
superstition no but okay I will read
fortune cookies and maybe think they're
true sometimes but other than that no no
no the thing is you don't go to it as an
Astrophysical astrology no definitely
not but here's what it is I have to
invest energy on occasion to not be
superstitious I feel the human urge on a
black cap Russia for not so much a
blanket but things like no do you step
on the crash and their pavement okay you
know I have to say
is stupid I'm just going to step on the
damn crack right so I have to overcome
what I know is a natural urge to be
superstitious so when I see other people
being superstitious I don't I don't
denigrate that so how do you be able to
think like yesterday mr. religion
yesterday Oh Tyra deal with yesterday
what do we have I do it I'm religion I
think is as practice I think is best
exemplified if you look at for example
the reformed Jewish community yes all
the Jewish rituals are there their
community rituals that's what they are
and they're excuses to come together you
know all of the Jews are doing the same
thing at the same time if it's a seder
for example and that has a bonding force
right for communities so I personally
I'm a big fan of rituals I love rituals
they're one of the things that are truly
and fundamentally human and I don't want
to ever forfeit something that
distinguishes us from all other life on
Earth and rituals are one of those
things now if you perform rituals that
compromise your health or the safety or
well health or someone else then that's
a problem yeah but other sort of simple
rituals I have no problems with it so in
the majesty of the universe of
complexity the Majesty that I mean it's
just it's a profoundly amazing thing
universities leave our spiritual I was
asked it was a part of you thinking
intelligent design there's some oh not
tell you why not okay yeah because every
now and then an asteroid comes and
renders everything extinct that you know
and what's going on like between your
legs there's this entertainment complex
in the middle of a sewage system none of
this is intelligent you can't call that
intelligence design that is like stupid
design right you just you just look at
our propensity to disease to birth
defects to to look at all the ways earth
wants to kill us right Earth has
succeeded at that for more than 97% of
all life that has ever lived on earth is
now extinct right because earth killed
it we talked about Mother Earth is in
the earth is a killing machine
but volcanoes hurricanes storms so to
say OS and tell if that's intelligent I
don't know what who you who were you
talking about
so that's intelligent I want to be
stupid when I look at the universe you
can see the beauty the glory the majesty
but don't dust under the rug all that
would end your life sooner than what is
natural and there's plenty of that out
there when you combine the two it's I
don't know what you're looking at so I
was reading Thomas Merton yesterday ok a
very famous American Catholic profound
thinker who feeds in the supernatural
and and seems to say things are that are
in concert with science but he still
believes that there's some kind of
something bigger and greater than I and
so I heard you talk about humility
before yeah before in the presence of
the universe in the presence of the US
and isn't that sort of about you bowing
down to like I'm a finite object the way
I can understand the infinite I will not
say that there's no way I can understand
it I will say I haven't understood it
yet right and it might take people much
smarter than I am born much later than I
have been to come to that understanding
but the progress of science since the
beginning until now has been incessant
and that's something that's one of the
great triumphs of that as an enterprise
as a thing that humans have figured out
they could do so all I'm saying is if
you want to look at the beauty of the
grandeur the majesty of the universe I'm
not going to stop you but don't have
don't let that blind you to everything
about the universe that is not in the
best interest of your health and
longevity and when you combine those two
it looks really random out there really
so you just think that this bad stuff is
randomly happening you don't think that
any items that the dinosaurs were pretty
unlucky because an asteroid came and
took him out right right they didn't
have a space program to deflect it right
yeah that that was really unlucky and
that asteroid took out 70% of all
species of life on Earth when it hit
right nothing bigger than a suitcase
survived and so that's some bad luck it
is and so when you look at the current
state of politics and you know that that
asteroid hit the next
so you have a president that sort of
anti Mexico do you do you I'm asking
around it that way do you support the
president first of all what when that
when the asteroid hit it wasn't called
Mexico just just an FYI so did I a
question I don't have 85 million years
ago so yes I've actually read a lot
about that and I produced a book and I
did a book club with the sixth
extinction oh cool yeah that's what
we're going on now yeah yeah what yeah
which is amazing but I guess doesn't so
is there a futility in hold and then why
are you so you're such a major force and
in trying to prick human action it would
be an action force but you seem to think
that this is all just a random colliding
of atoms and well so I will say that we
are smart enough all we need is the
vision add it to our smarts to be able
to protect ourselves from the fate that
the dinosaurs encounter because we know
how to deflect an asteroid right but we
have no system in place to do so for
your sense of faith you yet you do have
faith and it's fated demand and capacity
not oh I don't always have faith in
humanity that's private I have I have I
have some expectation that if you have
the option to die or not die you'll
choose the option to not die once you're
presented with the argument that will
convince you of that right but not
everyone has heard that argument or
understands that the solar system is a
shooting gallery and and you know earth
plows through 300 tons of meteors a day
a dead end Muslims are small so we're
cool yeah then they burn up so not a
promise just a shooting star we're cool
yeah but some of those are larger than
fits the ground others explode in midair
and occasionally a big one comes and I
don't want to be the laughingstock of
intelligent aliens in the galaxy if they
learn that we had a space program but
did not invoke it to prevent our
extinction from an asteroid we knew was
come
[Applause]
hey did you like that cool video huh
well how about a bunch of cool videos
all commercial free plus exclusive
original content that you can't find
anyplace else all on Startalk all-access
calm